so let's have a look at the first one
now you are so radiant and y intercept
why this s is the easy part you just
look at the graph and you're looking for
one spot gradient it's a bit more work
what is the way to set to see it it's
three right there he is right there you
get your y axis the vertical one and
you're just looking for that point so
the y-intercept is three greeting is a
bit trickier to work out so I want to
suggest how they actually not just the
other on how they actually went about
finding the radio yeah okay so you want
to find spot on the line that match up
nicely to these lines the grid lines
which place did you pick the this 1d
yeah and the one we've already well I
get perfect alright so if we take these
two points and it often helps i mean i
know you probably didn't draw a diagram
because you need to but since I've got
one I'm going to put on there if you
draw the rise and the run onto there and
then you can count your good squares you
can know what's going on what is the
rice for this particular pair of points
it goes 1 2 3 4 an hour on ears sue okay
now we know it's going up as you can see
it's going left to right increase in so
you're gonna get a positive number rise
over run yeah
so from we're about to let me go three
you mean to hear ya okay so what are the
interesting things under short answer is
yes what are interesting things to use
any combination of points like Renee
suggested these two and they look great
if I wanted to I could try another pair
of points like saying these two right
and I'm going to get the same ratio look
rises to Ronnies one same number ok so
our gradient to conclude is to write so
if you pick any combination um those
pair that you would have done there
would be three and one-half which again
gives you to laura's yeah question ah
you always have to be careful right so
it goes from you looking at this number
here yeah so this length here is going
from left to right that's always going
from left to right okay where is this
guy if I had a graph and it was sloping
downwards like this then this would be
negative because it's dropping ok so
correct we're always reading from left
to right so that would always be viewed
as I and it's not scared of confusing
feel like which way am I going down the
slide always go left to right ok I'm
just going to pause it for a second hey
you guys I want you to keep having a
conversation if you want to give you
never use the library I don't let you to
stop but
okay I just Rebecca me all right um not
the answer again can someone give me a
suggestion for the first line of working
for question two any takers what did you
do first okay go ahead okay so this guy
over here if we expanded it I'm getting
to and take away two are we happy with
that now what Georgia yeah okay so we're
going to multiply through so if i
multiply by 2 that will just leave me
with X these are all double happy with
that now what are we going to go
you subtracted 4x from both sides yeah
so that's why I'll now get rid of all
the X's over here and leave them on the
left-hand side that's perfect so if I've
got one here and I take away 4 of them
it's negatory good like that and then
you just got [ __ ] on both sides so i'm
going to divide through and i think
that's where I end yeah which line 1 2 3
4 which one your knives about 25 from
two to three yep okay so what i did was
i subtracted 4x from this side which
means i should subtract 4x from that
side as well okay so that makes this
Vash and x 10 x 4x collect like terms
cool all right now last one before we
actually do the country to someone
actually have a number what what do they
think that Aaron's gonna earn 330 yeah
not bad I do we agree with that number
okay let's just make sure we dissect
where it came from because there's a
really good chance in Canada's shoemark
question there's one of the marks the
other one is for how did you get there
how did you deny it up how did you go
about doing this what working did you
put down anyone would suggest to me what
a first line of working is here
IM ok good and equine a half times for
the double time yeah okay excellent so
this looks good to me when you see these
two things here I think it's very clear
where each one comes from I suppose you
could have written this as 2 times 20
but again it's one I think when my
students tend to have issues here is
calculating these guys right like it is
confusing especially when you go past
the girls tech position so should when
you go past noon or past midnight it's
like wait how coming do I count a common
error is thinking that it goes up to 10
instead of 12 but seven aha one way
another way you can check it come on 17
/ oh yeah okay sure another way you can
check it just as a confirmation is to
think about these days on 24-hour time I
don't know how comfortable you feel with
24-hour time if you're not comfortable
it's okay don't worry about it but if
you are it makes it very simple seat
watch you start at nine thirty right my
buddy what's 5pm in 24 hour times they
don't know he had seven seventeen
o'clock or we would say 1700 hours right
and then 930 will be 21 30 now when you
look at the numbers this way it's kind
of easier to see although the course
that's for it on right and you can just
do a subtraction here to see oh yeah of
course that's seven right so if you ever
sort of in doubt that's one of the ways
that you can confirm it's been a dream
with baby he's a lot of money for a
day's work then again you do pretty long
day but it was the double time it really
did